do you know somebody who has no friends
well here's a great gift idea for them a
few years ago my mother got me this
tic-tac-toe it's a book that will play
Tic-Tac-Toe with you it's a Choose Your
Own Adventure style book that begins
with an empty tic-tac-toe grid you start
just choose where to place an X then
turn to the corresponding page number
for example to play an X in the middle
go to page five sure enough on page five
there is your ex and the book is then
used its turn to play an O right up
there in the corner play proceeds just
like that until you lose or draw you see
the book plays perfectly there is some
kind of neat stuff about it for example
if you don't want to go first turn the
book over and read it backwards now the
book plays first also even though it
claims to be the book that will beat you
at Tic-Tac-Toe there's actually one
chain of decisions you can make
throughout this book along which the
book makes a mistake and you get to win
it is really fun
thank you Mom